triplement des vols sur les antilles
doublement sur la réunion c'est le
dispositif mis en place par paire france
en cette période estivale pour faire
face à l'afflux considérable de
passagers en direction des départements
d'outre-mer
c'est un véritable poumon aérien qui est
mis en place au moment des vacances
entre l'hexagone les antilles et la
réunion pour assurer un trafic qui
augmente de façon considérable
à cette époque de l'année les antillais
et les réunionnais rentrer en effet au
pays pour y passer leurs congés tous les
avions affiche complet et il faut s'y
prendre plusieurs mois al avance pour
être sûr d'avoir une place
et cela malgré les dispositions
exceptionnelles que prennent les
responsables d'air france sur 20 boeing
747 de 479 place la compagnie en
mobilise 10 sur ses deux seules
destinations soit près de la moitié de
la flotte des 747 et cela afin de
remplir sa mission de service public
nous allons réaliser pendant ces
périodes de pointe 40 fréquence c'est à
dire 40 rotation 80 vols sur les
antilles et 14 rotation c'est-à-dire 28
vols sur la réunion alors c'est une
performance technique assez considérable
pour vous faire réaliser un petit peu le
poids de cette performance technique il
faut savoir que nous avons transporté au
cours d'une de ces semaines de points
sur les antilles dix sept mille cinq
cents passagers
c'est à peu près l'équivalent d'une
petite ville comme hautain ou comme bar
le duc
ça veut dire que pendant une semaine ont
transplanté à travers l'atlantique
toute la population enfants bagages une
ville comme parle du couple moteur pour
assurer sa mission la compagnie
nationale n'hésite pas donc à mettre des
moyens énormes au service des passagers
à destination des antilles et de la
réunion
car en plus de la mobilisation des
avions il faut aussi considérer celle du
personnel pour assurer les réservations
les embarquements et les débarquements
et les services aux escales à noter par
ailleurs que si les avions partent plein
à trappier de l'hexagone
ils reviennent aux trois quarts vide